le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
le patrimoine réunionnais ces artistes
sont parfois méconnus pour nous
permettre de les découvrir de les
redécouvrir le département a eu l'idée
originale de créer des résidences
d'artistes au sein de neuf bâtiments
représentatifs du patrimoine culturel
réunionnais un projet innovant nommé
patrimoine et création qui vise à donner
de la visibilité et enrichir l'offre
culturelle soutenir la création
artistique tout en partageant avec le
public à travers la création dun
le projet patrimoine et création est née
cette année le département a reçu plus
d'une quarantaine de projets dix ont été
retenus et associé à une dizaine
d'établissements parmi les plus
prestigieux de lille là ce que je suis
en train de faire c'est faire qu'avec
les illustrations autour du café bourbon
pointu une planque on retrouve dans le
jardin créole en fait de moins en moins
malheureusement nicolas lau manioc est
l'un des dix candidats dans le projet
artistique intitulé carnet de voyage a
été sélectionné que le budget de faire
quelque chose d'artistique autour de ton
ces espèces là ce qui est avantageux en
fait c'est d'avoir accès à une partie
leurs connaissances la richesse en fait
du lieu quoi il ya un gros travail de
consommation qui est fait le travail
historique aussi en fait en replongeant
les vieux récits les vieilles planches
derbier la documentation elle qui est
pas forcément accessible à tout le monde
je peux faire une valorisation de ces
espèces qui sont certaines en train de
disparaître ou inexploités ou qu'ils
deviennent bientôt inexistante en faire
sur le territoire sa résidence au jardin
botanique des mascarins lui permet
d'avoir accès à tous les savoirs que
renferme le lieu à commencer par sa
mémoire vive en a besoin de savoir ce
que le nom scientifique du manioc mais
ça nous mangeons nom scientifique c
lescure ans l'artiste se renseignent
étudie s'inspire des explications des
botanistes du jardin mais il doit aussi
observer pour transmettre au public et
pour cela il a aussi accès à l'herbier
de l'établissement caverne d'ali baba
estimé diop en droit de le takamaka
comme une base de travail est
immensément précieuse puisqu'elle recèle
tous les trésors endémiques et indigènes
de la flore locale jeu de fragile de
francs on est plusieurs à recenser ce
vent d'espoir et à composer tout est
habillé que la nation fait ça ces
référents au mondial passé la firme
nokia et nous c'est le biais de travail
prennent à une grande chance de
travailler une note alors oui vallée des
plaisirs d'hérault plaisir aussi paraît
il et paraissait là parce que bon nous
il ya une oppression des comme ça
ah oui et en plus la passion c'est notre
médecine aussi en même temps il va
ensuite allé à la rencontre de son sujet
de création pleine nature dessinée
croquer de ses observations pour ensuite
mieux les partager
un moyen pour nicolas de renouer avec
ses racines j'ai beaucoup de choses que
j'ai pu emmagasiner reçoit au canada en
australie ou métropole je connais plus
serait jour là c'est de là qu'est née
l'idée carnet de voyage
on va faire des médiations des
rencontres des échanges de discussion
sur casque un jardin créole pourquoi on
a telle espèce dans le coin d'un jardin
et qu'on ne retrouve pas ailleurs après
on va faire un travail sur les personnes
porteurs de handicap au niveau du
travail de la terre des outils la
manipulation en parallèle jeune public
ils seront invités à participer à de la
création sur comment réaliser un quart
des voyages le but c'est retranscrire
tout le travail qui a été fait par le
conservatoire
le jardin botanique les groupes de
médiation et moi même essayé de faire un
rendu au public le plus naturellement
possible on va dire comme si quoi dans
la nature un projet artistique comme un
devoir de mémoire qui a pu voir le jour
grâce notamment au soutien financier du
département
la volonté du département c'est de
mettre en valeur le patrimoine et la
création ils vont pouvoir utiliser le
patrimoine qui ne sont pas exposées et
ils vont avoir aussi un travail
important à faire avec nos publics
montrer la richesse que nous possédons
en termes patrimoniale en termes
d'artistes et de créativité
les artistes vont avoir une bourse
mensuelle de 2000 euros pendant la durée
de leur projet nous allons aussi leur
donner les moyens d'accompagner tous mus
qu'ils aient besoin autour de leur
projet à hauteur de 14 mille euros tous
les champs disciplinaires sont concernés
arts vivants arts visuels écriture
compte ou encore le chant c'est cette
dernière discipline qui a été retenu au
musée de villèle sur un projet de
christine salem accompagné d'une artiste
américaine cela un projet particulier
que les c'est tout ce qui est son
d'esclaves en fait c'est un échange avec
deborah that à l'époque aux états unis
et moi les chansons que moi même écrit
sur l'histoire de l'escaladé le dieu les
paires magique
elle appela d'émotion et surtout comme
ils répètent sur la tombe de même des
bassins dont on sait qu'on a quelque
chose quoi
bonne chance que mes écrits sur 20 m des
bassins seul esclavage est de chanter ça
ici ça donne une force
mambia de la paix intérieure dans
l'histoire d'une nation ne peut pas
changer c'est comme ça bien de temps en
temps rappelé un petit peu des
résidences d'artistes se situe dans neuf
bâtiments de différentes natures et
trois musées du département le lazaret
de la grande chaloupe la bibliothèque
départementale
les archives l'artothèque l'icône au tac
historique de l'océan indien ou encore
le jardin botanique des mascarins la
durée de résidence des artistes est
comprise entre 3 et 6 mois
une première édition qui au vu de son
succès en appellera de nombreuses autres
rapidement
[Applaudissements]
les résidences d'artistes se sont mais
ce bâtiment du patrimoine local au sein
desquelles une dizaine d'artistes
peuvent créer une oeuvre à destination
du public par cette action le
département souhaite soutenir la
création artistique
il offre une bourse de 2000 euros par
mois pendant six mois maximum à
l'artiste qui est investi le lieu une
démarche qui permet aussi de valoriser
le patrimoine réunionnais pour plus
d'informations rendez vous sur le site
internet du département www.gg.ca de
quatre point fr
[Musique]